brought to you by Assassin's Creed unity
make history with friends available now
hey guys it's a 13-4 November today my
name is just Whittle and you're watching
games what news you may have noticed had
you been on the internet recently that
there are more than a few screencaps
going around depicting Assassin's Creed
unity technical issues the nightmare
fuel graphical glitches include those
which show only teeth and eyeballs on
the background of hair but these bugs
aren't the only ones as illustrated by
the number of players who found various
issues in the game's code you don't have
to look hard to find videos of floating
characters people missing their faces
and NPCs driving invisible carts and I
would highly recommend you check that
stuff out for comedy value Ubisoft have
acknowledged the extent of the problems
and promised to fix priority issues like
honour falling through the ground and
getting caught inside of hay cards which
is not where you want to be when you
have quests to do and women to Mack on
with your no face shares in Ubisoft fell
nine percent on Wednesday with investors
losing faith in the publishers capacity
to deliver on their games a lot of us
are in the same doubt boat but we mostly
just have our fingers crossed for the
division you can play dragon age
inquisition right now if you find
yourself with an Xbox one and a
subscription to EA access okay so having
both of those things might be a bit of a
tall order but a full six hour trial for
next week's open-world RPG will be
available to those of you who do EA
access cost you five bucks a month or
thirty dollars a year that comes with
handy perks like these getting into
games early and grabbing yourself a ten
percent discount on the full game your
progress in the trial will all be saved
for you too so there's that that server
side update came through for halo the
master chief collection but it hasn't
alleviated all the issues while some
users are getting into matches quicker
others are still experiencing
unreasonably long wait times to get into
the game in an attempt to fix the
problem 343 industries even boosted the
number of plays you can enter a match to
5v five instead of four before but this
can
great its own balancing issues 343 are
continuing to promise that they're
working around the clock to fix the
issues after your question of the day
let me know what you think of ubisoft's
latest games and if you're into
Assassin's Creed unity you can ads
against wat for more stories on things
like GTA 5 online mode and the first
level 100 players in wow that is it for
me today do you remember that tomorrow
I've got the five best stories of the
whole gaming week so subscribe and I
hope to see you then